- Bae, squad, fleek, basic,
no cap, bet, yaaaaas,
turn up, spilling tea, got
receipts, keep it 100, finesse.
These are just a few terms and phrases
that originated in black communities
And have become popularized--
Some might say co-opted--by
mainstream American culture,
but this trend predates
the internet by decades.
Americans have long embraced contributions
to popular language
from African-Americans,
arguably more than they've been willing
to embrace the people themselves.
This cultural dissonance is just one part
of the long complicated history
of African-American English.
And to unpack it, I'm
joined by sociolinguist
and AAE researcher, Dr.
Rachel Elizabeth Weissler.
- AAE can go by several different names:
African-American Language,
African-American Vernacular
English, and Black English.
"Ebonics" was coined in 1973
by African-American
psychologist Robert Williams.
But since then, it has been
co-opted by white speakers
as a derogatory term
and thus is not used by
language researchers.
Despite the Internet's
obsession with slang,
AAE is a lot more than a
collection of colloquialisms.
It is a complete and distinct sociolect,
a dialect created by social
rather than regional boundaries.
It is perhaps one of the most
culturally impactful varieties
of English on earth, but
also the most misunderstood.
- Other words.
- In 1619, the English privateer
ship, white lion landed
at Point Comfort in Virginia.
Onboard were 20 enslaved
Africans who were traded
for supplies.
This transaction is of great historical
and linguistic significance,
because it marks the beginning
of slavery in British colonial America,
and the beginning of
African-American English.
- The millions of people
kidnapped from Africa
and forced into slavery
in North America came
from more than 45 distinct ethnic groups
and spoke many different languages.
In most cases, they couldn't communicate
with each other or their captors,
but communication is
necessary for survival.
And in this language contact situation,
the enslaved people were
forced to learn the language
of their captors, made
all the more difficult
by the fact that they were
not allowed to read or write.
In adopting English, heritage
languages were slowly lost,
though some words did manage to survive
in our lexicon to this day,
such as yam, banjo and okra.
- There are several theories
about the foundations of AAE.
Perhaps it began as a pidgin,
a hastily developed form of communication
between groups that don't
share a common tongue,
or maybe it was the result of
English words being dropped
into African grammar systems.
But the most popular theory
is that it grew out of the
English dialect spoken
by white rural southerners of the time.
In this region, slavery and
then segregation kept black
and white community separated
creating an environment favorable
to maintaining distinct
varieties of English.
In the 20th century,
millions of African-American
seeking opportunities
and fleeing racial persecution relocated
to large metropolitan areas in the north
known as The Great Migration,
which is why today AAE is
associated with urban areas.
There is a glaring misconception
that AAE is a wrong
or deficient version
of what people call
Mainstream American English
or Standardized American English,
but that isn't the case at all.
And when it comes to language,
views about right and
wrong are often forms
of social prejudice.
AAE has its own rules of
grammar, usage and pronunciation
that are as elegant and
consistent as any other dialect.
And contrary to negative stereotypes,
speakers of AAE are not
careless with language.
Like all people, they're very aware
of the rules of their native dialect
and instantly know when
they're broken or misused.
- Are you sure that you wanna get turned
with your girls this weekend?
- I promised them a free
trip and it's turnt with a T
- No matter what kind
of English you speak,
you're going to sound different if you're
from New York City,
Atlanta, or Philadelphia,
and the regional phonetic
variation in AAE reflects that.
However, there are some
common phonological features.
TH stopping, where a
D sound replaces a TH,
so that this and that
might be dis and dat.
TH can also be replaced by an F or a V,
so nothing and smooth
might be noffing and smoov.
Consonant cluster reduction,
where multiple continents
at the end of a word
are simplified into one.
So for example, lift and test
might sound like lif and tes.
The common pronunciation of ask as aks
is an example of metathesis
in which two speech sounds
are allowed in flexible order.
Many English words were
derived through metathesis.
For example, bird and horse
used to be bridd and hros.
Several others are
currently undergoing it,
like nucular, introduce and prescription.
- In addition to sound
features, AAE often differs
from other types of
American English in grammar,
which is fairly constant
across the country.
One of the most maligned
features of AAE's grammar
is the so-called double negative.
As in, I ain't see nobody,
but this disparagement
reflects a misunderstanding
of how language works.
Language isn't like math,
where two negatives cancel each other out.
In many languages like
Spanish, Greek and Hebrew,
a second negative serves to confirm
or amplify the negation
known as negative concord.
For instance, the Spanish
sentence "No vi a nadie,"
literally translates
to "I didn't see nobody."
Even standardized American
English employs a bit
of negative Concord.
If you wanna make this sentence negative,
you have to adjust the
verb and the object.
The "anybody" serves the
same function as "nobody,"
to remind the listener that
the statement is negative.
- Some other grammatical features
of AAE include: possessive S absence.
Instead of "the man's hat" or "my mama's car,"
you'd have "the man hat" or "my mama car."
Question word order.
Instead of "why aren't they going?"
You might hear "why they ain't going."
"Finna", which etymologists trace back
to the Southern phrase "fixing to"
might replace "going to" or "gonna."
"I'm going to go to the store,"
might be "I'm finna go to the store."
Zero copula, the connecting
verb "to be" can be removed
from sentences where they
would form a contraction.
So, "who is that" might become "who dat,"
and "she's my sister" might
become "she my sister."
Other languages like Japanese and Russian
also employs the zero copula.
For instance, "ona doma" literally
translates to "she at home."
No S on third person singular.
MAE changes form only for
third person singular verbs.
I run, you run, she
runs, we run, they run,
only one S in there.
AAE keeps all verb forms
consistent and regular.
In many cases,
AEs verb conjugation can
actually achieve more nuance
and precision than
mainstream American English.
When I say "she is working,"
I generally mean one of two
things, either she has a job
or she is currently doing work right now.
In AAE, those are differentiated.
"She working" means that
she is currently working
at this moment, and "she be
working" means that she works
on a regular basis.
And the third option, "she been working."
She is working and has been for a while.
- Now, some of these features
also occur in other varieties
of English and not all of them are used
by every speaker of AAE.
But taken together, they index AAE,
which means they serve
as a sign that points
to a shared history and cultural identity.
Because of history is
fraught with tension,
discrimination and violence,
it's not surprising
that AAE is considered
a controversial topic.
It is the most broadly studied
variety of American English
and has been the subject of
many high profile court cases
over issues like school instruction
and linguistic profiling
in employment and criminal justice.
Attitudes of stigma and language prejudice
have forced many speakers
of AAE to be bidialectal,
able to speak both AAE
and whatever's considered
the mainstream norm of their region.
Alternating between two
different dialects or languages
or social linguistic practices
is called "code switching."
It can occur casually, the
way bilingual children
of Spanish speaking
parents will transition
from English to Spanish, back
to English in one sentence.
But it can also be socially mandated.
Say, if you speak in a
formal register of Japanese
with many honorifics
when addressing your boss
versus the more colloquial
language you may use
with your pals.
- Most speakers of AAE are
adept at switching to MAE based
on context and setting
like a job interview
or other professional situation.
- You wanna make some money here?
Use your white voice.
- My white voice.
- Hey, Mr. Kramer, this is
Langston from Regal View.
- But this skill is not
without its struggles.
Having to constantly
scan social situations
and adjust one speech patterns
is a layer of extra mental effort
that white speakers don't
have to worry about.
And speakers of AAE may face blow back
from their own communities
when code switching,
being accused of trying to sound white.
- You never wanna be the
whitest sounding black guy
in a room.
- There's also the question
of why they should have to
change the way they speak at all
just to make others more comfortable.
It can be frustrating to know
that despite the linguistic evidence,
many Americans still
hear AAE as an inferior
or wrong version of
mainstream American English.
- And yet ironically, AAE is also one
of the most copied and
co-opted English dialects.
Some non-black speakers might
use features of the dialect
to show affiliation with African-Americans
or with traits they might
stereotypically associate
with them, like confidence,
coolness or toughness.
♪ Yeah, I keep my TEC-9 on my waist
cause I'm a gangster ♪
- I know they don't mean any harm,
but they don't realize how ignorant it is.
Trying to have that black voice
that some whites try to do,
but they really don't do well.
- There are people like myself
who do know what they're
saying and could do it.
I think, I honestly think I could.
(audience laughing)
- Both American pop culture
and youth culture rely on
and are shaped by black
cultural practices,
products and behaviors,
including music and language.
As these cultural elements radiate outward
from urban centers to
the rest of the world,
slang expressions that
originated in AAE are constantly
being adopted by other groups, groups
that don't necessarily
understand the background,
context and appropriate usage,
but enjoy the social clout they bring.
- AAE is a part of the
cultural inheritance
of many African-Americans.
And the strong sense of cultural identity
is also one of oppositionality,
of embracing the contrast
with other groups and
broader white society.
The history that shaped AAE
has more than its fair share
of tragedy and violence,
the societal effects
of which we are still living with today.
But the negative associations
that many people attach
to AAE cause us to overlook
the triumphs, perseverance,
and creativity that gave
African-American culture
an outsized role on the world stage.
Language, it turns out
is more a reflection
of the overcoming of obstacles
than the obstacles themselves.
- Do what, what are you talking?
- I think I could write
for you in your vernacular
because of-
- But what is my vernacular?
- Well, because I hang out with-
- Yeah, but what is my vernacular?
What are you talking about?
- Well, like this hog is all on my yoke.
- Right, Dick, what are you talking about?
(audience laughs)